so the new Robocop trailer is out I got
a lot of tweets like instantly have you
seen it what are your thoughts so here
are my thoughts as far as the original
Robocop film goes I enjoy it I never
really grew up with it or anything it
wasn't like the film that was playing
all the time in my household I saw it I
enjoyed it I had fun with it it was a
well-made film especially for the 80s
and yeah it's a good film but I'm not
like deathly close to it in the heart
but I have nothing against it either and
I know a lot of people are tired of
remix myself included I think that
basically everything that was popular in
the 80s is officially gonna be remade no
matter what it is it's just gonna happen
apparently and even films that came out
in like the year 2000 like American
Psycho they're talking about remaking
that and you know it's just going
overboard one thing that does give me
confidence is the recent remake of Dredd
I don't really know why it gives me
confidence because as far as I know no
one involved with Dredd is involved with
Robocop but it's just Robocop and read
kind of had similar elements to me
except for the first one with Sylvester
Stallone was terrible so this is a kind
of movie that should be remade you know
a movie that was terrible but had a cool
concept
so let's remake it and make it good and
they did with Dredd Robocop was a good
movie that doesn't necessarily need
remade but I've pretty much accepted
that everything happens like that
nowadays and it's just gonna happen so
I'll go and see it but this movie
actually doesn't look that bad it looks
alright and so I'm a little bit
optimistic about it for one thing the
director of this movie hasn't really
done anything huge in America he's made
two foreign films that are pretty
popular called elite squad and in the
sequel to that and those apparently are
actually pretty good I haven't checked
them out yet so I do have some
confidence that this director knows how
to film action and for that reason I am
optimistic about this film the trailer
does not look too bad
Gary Oldman Michael Keaton you got some
big names in there does that necessarily
mean it's gonna be good of course not
Gary Oldman was just in paranoia but
this movie actually doesn't look too bad
this suit looks pretty cool the action
looks good you can't really fail at
certain things with Robocop unless you
suck at filmmaking there's a few things
that have to happen the suit has to look
good there has to be fun action you have
to care about the characters overall and
the thrust of the story and you have to
not poop on the original if they can do
that then Robocop will be a fun movie
and I hope they do those are my thoughts
in the trailer it looks alright it
doesn't actually look that bad to me I
hope it is good I'm
keeping a little bit of skepticism just
in case it really sucks because it could
I don't know but actually it doesn't
look like it does what do you guys think
of the trailer do you think remake
should stop I mean they're gonna happen
I think that there's too many of them
but I do think it would be nice if
Hollywood toned it down a little bit
what are your guys thoughts on the whole
remake thing and the trailer of course
thank you very much for watching guys
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes